today's question comes from ginger in
california
she writes my husband refuses to deposit
his whole check in our joint account and
hides money in a separate account
he deposits only enough to cover our
expenses
then turns around and withdraws large
amounts later
he's a good father holy crap don't want
to ruin my kid's life if we divorce
that's it so number one he's not a good
father
number two he's ruining your kids lives
not you being forced to do something
about this
so there's not really a question here
dave this is more of a statement
yeah your husband is a twerp
he is not husband material he is not
father material
he is a self-centered little child
yes and he's yeah
he's doing just enough to keep his kids
fed and you
fed but he's a manipulative power hungry
idiot and then he doesn't even care
about y'all being fed later on
because he'll go get the money back yeah
so
uh what does she do from here um
sits with a counselor absolutely and
then she's
the fact that she said i don't want to
ruin my kids lives if we divorce tells
me two things number one she's thought
about it or number two the people in her
life have said you're this is over.
and so she has built this up as i'm not
going there
and so i have met with people who have
said i won't do that
and to which you say okay then this is
the
bed you're choosing to be in you're
gonna have to make the best of what you
got inside of here
going to tell her this type of
manipulation
usually comes with violence and or
volume and or other types of neglect and
manipulation beyond just the money this
is a symptom
right and she's got to sit with a
counselor and begin to create a
or what plan because this is a mess yeah
and it's the uh to give you the strength
um the assurance that you're not crazy
correct
or wrong correct and the words
the narrative on how to calmly
lay down what will eventually become an
ultimatum right
or what yeah yeah and you're going to
say you're either going to
provide for this family by putting your
whole check in the thing and we're all
going to work together
or we're going to talk about how we're
ending this marriage because i'm not
going to live like this anymore
and these kids are not going to be
raised with you as a model
for what a husband and a father and a
provider looks like yeah
because yeah you're damaging your
children by allowing them to think he's
a good father
yes you're throwing gasoline on a legacy
forest fire yeah you're
there because they're going to duplicate
what he does times 10
yeah right yeah and to the extent he's
yelling at you then they're going to
yell and hit
yeah and to the to the extent that a
the mother of your children is simply an
annoyance and in the way of whatever
thing you need to buy whatever event you
need to attend
that's how they're going to treat
romantic partners for the rest of their
life
yeah and you're just you're painting a
model here's what that looks like
yeah my life is more important than all
of y'all's combined
my wants and toys and fun and stuff yeah
the opposite of this is we often tell
people what is the best thing you can do
for your children
love their mother well that's it when
somebody says that's the exact opposite
of this whole thing
how do i help my kid with uh screw my
kids up drinks mistreat their mother
that's exactly right hey my kids got
anxiety what i do fix your marriage
hey my kids are struggling with xyz fix
your marriage
have a great marriage start there and
then we'll start talking about the other
stuff
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry ginger i'm
sorry it's a horrible thing
it's not even a question here it's a
horrible thing you're in but the uh
if if um you know what we're seeing
you know with what you the information
you gave us uh was not throwing your
husband under the bus if it was truthful
and it is accurate and um then you are
sitting in a mess
and you need to do something about it
that's what we're saying and you
probably
are gonna need some help to do something
about it it's very few people can
navigate these things by themselves you
need someone to give you language to it
and someone to say look what you're
feeling in your heart that this is wrong
and you're being mistreated is correct
it's accurate it's accurate because you
start to feel like you're the problem
and you're not the problem it's almost a
domestic abuse thing and here look at
what she says i don't want to be the one
who ruins my kids lives yeah
by taking care of me and my children you
know what he has said that to her
absolutely if you leave me you'll
destroy these kids
if you don't quit yelling at me about
the money you're gonna you're gonna mess
these kids up
and she says oh my gosh i'm so sorry i'm
so sorry yeah that
it's got the same tone of a domestic
violence that's why you said violence
yeah